yeah but i but we also do different
types of comedy in that i'm singularly
storytelling mm-hmm so like i don't
really have a lot of what like i i'm
mine for takes like i love it
i'm not good at takes i've never been
good at takes because they're always
wrong
and so like that's the fun part yeah no
but make the best wrong take integrally
wrong like at the core of american
values wrong
and so really exciting
this is the best way to promote
especially
but uh but
i like
finding
i like i like storytelling so oddly
enough you can you can fine-tune
storytelling
just about anywhere well you know the
beauty of storytelling too it's very
repeatable the machine
doesn't ever get tired
you do that with your friends yo tell
them the story about your idea yeah it's
it's it's it's like ron white's tater
salad story yeah let me tell you
something i
i mean wrong i offered ron white
i wanted i was i can't really get into
it but i wanted to work with him and i
and he knows this and one of my caveats
is like i mean i didn't say this isn't
why we weren't working together but i
wanted to hear the tater salad story
every [ __ ] night
it's one of the best stories i've ever
told in stand up yeah without you know
it right yeah it's the you know what i
don't know
i'll just go watch it
it's the beauty you watch it's right
you've seen people rip it off because
people have taken the structure of his
story i told you that story to tell you
this story yeah people rip that off
because it's so well done right and uh
and
i was like i would watch him tell that
every single night i could watch him
every single night tell that yeah
he ended up retiring from stand up and
no i think he's still doing santa the
highway
wire act of a take that's really crazy
is once you've heard the crazy take and
then have heard how they justify it a
lot of people like all right cool that
was amazing but i've done it now the
story for some reason you can if you
have a your friend has a funny story
you'll make him tell it to everybody
when you're around that's how we
organize the world that's how we
remember things stories like we're
attracted to stories there's a reason to
bible stories right it's not hey here's
just the rules here's how the rules play
out in real life jesus had great takes
facts you know but
the taste stick yeah i'll i'll be honest
i like the hot take baked into a story
and i think that like the most
compelling bits
that i have
are when those things merge yeah so what
is the take on this crazy thing that's
happening and also how does it relate to
me or my friends in our real life and
then becomes memorable and like i don't
know people's attention span for stories
i know this is different like
if you're just going here's the take
it's like you better be funny quick with
that [ __ ] yeah but with a story if it's
like if the the premise is set
interesting they're like okay where are
we going wait so you're walking down the
alley and then what happened in the
alley and then this and it's like
i don't know just people the way they're
drawn to story
yeah it is a stronger connection i think
well it took me a while to to realize
what you were just saying
and for real because i was like i tell a
story and then everyone's like cool but
you like if you have to think to
yourself why am i telling this story
yeah like what does this story mean at
the base what am i telling this story
about am i talking about uh
your kids maturing are you talking about
some are just funny some are just funny
like my daughter isla has had a bunch of
things in her life that are just
[ __ ] hilarious the kids said same
with georgia but uh
and some are not you know some are just
you know get things up and running so i
could tell a story
but uh but like what you said if you can
present
you know like an idea or a take within a
story oh it's [ __ ] but i love i love
good stories man i love and i love i
love people
who have great stories and can't tell
great stories
my cameraman you met john manz has the
most interesting
things have ever happened to him and he
can't tell a story to save his [ __ ]
life what makes someone good at telling
a story uh you need a beginning and a
middle and an end it's an arc you need
to plan something in the beginning and
you need you people need to know your
story's over you
if
if you're if you tell a story and then
you're like and then you know we all
just got our cars went home everyone's
like
like with the machines i'll use a
machine store as an example
uh the end to me was
uh the way i delivered it on rogue in
the first time was
tonight you party with us but that
wasn't the end i didn't know that but
the audience knew it's not over did you
party with them
and i
and i did but i could and i kept trying
to figure out the ending and it wasn't
until one night in columbus that i
i
was drunk it always helps if you're
strolling stories get your story up and
running get it good and then get drunk
and tell it because you'll [ __ ] it up
and then [ __ ] up as a comic on your
feet you try to fix it and you're fixing
it can make it better yeah and so and
one night i was drunk in columbus and i
go igor shuts the door uh spits vodka in
her eyes
and
shuts the door in her face and then he
looks at me and i was like i was drunk
and he was like
and they used to say this a lot [ __ ]
that [ __ ] this is russia they said that
all the time [ __ ] like people didn't
understand this is russia the rules are
different here and i said that to me and
as soon as i said that in that story i
went ah i got my end now i have the
words so that people know the story is
over and that's the most quotable thing
[ __ ] that [ __ ] this is russia is at the
end tonight she party with us i lean in
and i go and i remember it working for
the first time and i'm and going like
it's such a great feeling when you go i
did it it's done like it's like sticking
a pole ball you're like oh i did it and
i said he says tonight's your party
though i'm not in trouble and he gets so
close i can smell his morning cigarette
and he's like no
[ __ ] that [ __ ] this is rasha and it
said twice that's the beauty of like a
great story is when you can i would say
plant a sapling a sapling to harvest it
at the end yeah and just a little
something they don't
they don't need to it can't be too big
yeah it's the beauty of tater salad yeah
they call me tater salad it's [ __ ]
it's a banger story dude you know who's
great reward the audience for paying
attention yeah jim jeffries yeah can
tell you a story with no preparation
yeah that guy is so [ __ ] talented
yeah i saw we did a story already a
storytelling show one night did he tell
the [ __ ] the friend one
that one's hilarious taking his [ __ ]
friend to the hooker no no no oh my god
dude you know who told a banger story
one night was bill burr
was told and he's not traditionally a
storytelling guy yeah
dude he told the story about doing the
college and getting underpaid by the
chick and then
i'm not gonna tell the whole thing
because it's bill and he's a pretty
private guy but he told
this [ __ ]
and it's bill
so his takes are embedded in it you know
yeah [ __ ] chick you know they got a
[ __ ] check and
we were just sitting in the back
everyone's on the edge of their seat
like holy [ __ ] ali sadiq's a great
storyteller mexicans got on boots i mean
dude i love a good story that's one of
my favorite thing my favorite thing in
the world is like sit down tell them
about the time and you're like oh
yeah yeah i i have always wanted to be a
better storyteller and i think i'm going
to take up drinking
i think that's been the key that's been
missing try it big the big story i mean
hemingway was a big drinker yo yo you're
on to something buddy guys thank you so
much for watching that clip from the
flag or two podcast and i just need to
let you know it is march madness and the
national championship is up for grabs
and so is the bag with my bookie sign up
today at my bookie and use the promo
code flagrant to secure a first deposit
bonus up to 1 000 it's simple deposit
200 and play with 300 instantly just use
the promo code flagrant to claim your
bonus mobile or on the go college or nba
no matter the league no matter the
minute my bookie puts the action in your
hands so you can turn any game day into
a payday bet anything anytime anywhere
with my bookie